-I´m so happy to have you here.
-I´m so happy to be here.
Thank you.
It´s my first talk show ever.
-It´s your first talk show.
-Yes.
-I´m so honored
to have you here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, we --
Before you were a cast member,
we wrote together at "SNL."
And I want to make sure I have
my timeline right,
because then you wrote and
performed on the "Maya & Marty"
variety special...
-Yep.
...before you were a cast member
at "SNL?"
-Correct, yeah.
-And how was your time working
with Maya and Marty short?
-It was fantastic.
Those two are amazing.
-Yeah.
-Martin Short would
totally mess with me.
-Uh-huh.
-He likes to take people down,
in a fun way.
-He really does.
-We would be shooting sketches,
and there would be
a studio audience.
And then during stop downs,
it was kind of quiet
and the studio audience were
just kind of looking at us.
And he´d be like, "Mikey, tell
everyone what it´s like to be
the least famous person here."
[ Laughter ]
He´s just kind
of like that dude.
-Yeah.
-But he´s so endearing.
He´s very charming.
-Yeah, it was fantastic.
-So, you wrote --
And as somebody
who wrote on the show,
I have inherent jealousy
when someone writes a hit.
Because David S. Pumpkins was
an immediate hit of a sketch.
-Yeah, it was very fun.
-Yeah.
-It was interesting.
Tom Hanks is amazing.
-Yeah.
This sketch is so popular,
not only did it explode
as a Halloween costume --
This is a Madam Tussaud´s
David S. Pumpkins.
-Yeah, and that´s fantastic.
What´s awesome about this is you
can tell they just put
a David Pumpkins suit
on an existing Tom Hanks...
-Yeah, you´re right.
-...because he´s so calm.
And I think this is in the room
that was, like,
a Hollywood party.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Because it´s just clearly
Tom Hanks, like, "Hi."
-I´m so mad at myself
that I did not realize
that´s what they did.
I can´t believe how quickly
they made a new wax Tom Hanks.
-I know, right?
Let´s make David Pumpkins
just chilling with
a nice smile on his face.
-So, now you have an animated
David S. Pumpkins special.
-Yep.
-You are one of the voices.
You co-wrote it.
-Yeah, with Bobby Moynihan
and Streeter Seidell.
-This is animated special.
-Yep.
-It looks a little bit --
It´s got, like, some Saturday
morning cartoon graphics.
-It´s got a very old-school kind
of throwback animation style.
-For kids?
-Is it kid-friendly?
-Yeah.
That´s how it came to be.
We -- Especially
after the sketch, like,
seeing social media and
a lot of kids dressing up
as David Pumpkins.
I saw YouTube videos of kids
acting out the sketch
from beginning to end.
And we thought it would be fun
to do a Halloween special, like,
with David Pumpkins for kids.
Because David pumpkins is
kind of like a kid himself.
I mean, this thing
is very like --
My 5-year-old son does
that type of thing,
you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
So we decided to gear
it towards kids.
And there´s a lot of --
There´s kind of like
a leaving cookies
for Santa Claus.
-Uh-huh.
-There´s the David Pumpkins
equivalent, you know, for kids.
-Now I do want to point out your
time-slot for your cartoon
for kids is 11:30
on Saturday night.
-Yeah, exactly.
Which is very David Pumpkins...
-Yes.
-...because you have questions.
-You immediately have questions.
-Yeah.
It also might be
there was no room.
And Lorne gave us
the first half hour of "SNL."
But --
-I feel like I´m going to
turn on
Saturday morning cartoons
and it´s going to be
like a Keith Morrison "Dateline"
about the grisliest
Halloween murders.
And I´ll be like, "You guys
should have flipped these."
"This is in
the wrong time slot."
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-So --
-Yeah -- you --
Bobby Moynihan was here
and talked a little bit
about the origins of sketch.
Originally --
And then we have
the Bobby cartoon and then
we have the you cartoon.
-Yeah.
And he said himself, he said,
"We should be left skeleton
and fat skeleton."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Like -- and I said,
"No, you´re right skeleton."
-You´ve been
a writer now since 2013.
One of my favorite
things to ask --
sketches that you have pitched
that have not found their way
to the show.
-There are so many.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There was one I wrote
with Streeter Seidell,
who I wrote the David Pumpkins
sketch and the special with.
-Yes.
Great writer, as well.
-We thought it was so funny.
It was a commercial parody
for a car security system
that would guarantee that no
thief would break into your car.
-Mm-hmm.
-And it was a bag of
old McDonald´s on --
on the floor
in your passenger seat.
[ Light laughter ]
And you could tell
by the audience.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it was a huge hit...
-Yeah, sure.
-...at the table read.
-Yeah, yeah.
I´m sure Lorne´s going
to watch that when he hears
that audience lose their mind.
"Oh, my gosh!
It needs to go straight to air!"
But, we thought --
-So, was the idea
a criminal would see the bag --
-Yeah, it would, like --
It had testimonials
from car thieves and --
You know, they were like,
"Look, if I´m going
to break into a car and I see
a bag of old McDonald´s
on the floor, like, I know
it´s going to smell bad,
have that old McDonald´s smell."
-Yeah.
"And there´s ten other cars on
this block that don´t smell."
And then there was
a deluxe system
that had a leash and
a wet towel in the back seat.
-Gotcha.
-And it was like --
like you took
your dog to the beach.
-Right, there you go.
-And we --
Streeter and I were like,
"Oh, this is going to crush."
-Yeah.
-And then it was just nothing.
And we´re like, "Okay,
we hate this now."
It´s so funny how quickly --
-Uh, anything else?
-We had a --
with Brian Tucker,
we had a sketch
of Mortal Kombat.
It was a few years ago,
Mortal Kombat X was coming out.
-Right.
-And Pete was playing
a video game and it --
You know those character select
screens where it´s like,
"Choose your fighter,"
and it´s like,
"Raiden. Scorpion."
It just --
And then it was like, "Raiden.
Scorpion, Sonya."
And then it went to Kevin Hart.
-Uh-huh.
-And he looked like Flavor Flav,
I would say.
And he just went,
[ High voice ] "Crazy cheese!"
[ Normal voice ]
And then Pete was like, "What?"
And then, of course,
he did not want Crazy Cheese.
And it was like, "You´ve
selected Crazy Cheese."
-Gotcha.
-And then I just remember
his combo move was Leslie Jones
came out as his girlfriend
and went, "I´m Karen!"
[ Laughter ]
So it was a little
too complicated.
Maybe some day.
-Some day.
-Um -- uh.
-Yeah.
-Judging by the audience
response Mortal also --
-I think --
"SNL" is back next week.
I think we can look forward to
both McDonald´s security system
and Crazy Cheese.
-Yeah, it´s going to dominate
the show.
-I can´t wait to see the
special.
Thank you very much
for being here, Mikey.
-Thank you, I love you.
-It´s just such a pleasure.